I had a non traditional
path to Wall Street.
But what's cool that wasn't
a typical feeder school.
And at the last second I gave
consideration to doing the two
year analyst program on Wall Street.
By frankly, I had a little bit of
success and unexpected success and
fell in love with Wall Street
decided to stay in the industry, and
progressed through my career.
Why I gravitated to Stanford was really
around the innovation, disruption,
some of the the technology aspects and
how the world is going to be different 10,
20, 30 years from now.
In the belief that you need
this sort of background and
understanding all of these currents to
be a successful leader in the future.
Silicon Value in my opinion has
woken up to this industry and
wanting to disrupt it.
I think financial institutions
really need to figure out and
I think they're doing it in a lot of ways.
How do I take this underlying industry if
you rely on the disruption side seriously.
How do I figure out how to work with them?
How do I figure out how
to partner with them?
Being out at Stanford,
sitting in Palo Alto,
meeting with all
the venture capital funds,
seeing what the professors are talking
about, what the students are learning.
It made me realize that innovation and
disruption is really here to stay.
You can't compete with it.
[MUSIC]